talking about the age of disclosure and
we hear all the time on the globe side
you've got Threeey Atlas which is
apparently making its way towards Earth.
We know that there was um there's UFO
sightings and crop circles have been in
pop culture for years and years and
years now. And u they just came out with
a documentary called Age of Disclosure
talking about how there's government
personnel officials, 34 of them
apparently, that are saying, "Hey, we
have recovered alien technology that we
have reverse engineered and that's what
we're now being prepared for that hey
any day now aliens could either a make
contact or the government could say you
know what they are real there's
something going on here." So what do you
guys think we should start with? But I
love this topic.
H.
>> Well, I want to know since we're all
flat earthers in here, right, everyone?
>> Six people?
>> Yep.
>> Well, what do what do you guys think
about an alien who says he's coming from
another planet?
>> Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> But they're seeing something, right?
>> Not happening.
>> So, people are seeing something, though.
>> Have an encounter.
>> I've never had a an alien encounter. I
don't I don't I've never had that. But I
I've been obsessed with aliens my whole
life. My room had aliens hanging from
the ceiling. I had
>> Oh, I love that.
>> Yeah. My favorite movie from 1993, I was
like third grade was Fire in the Sky. I
saw it. Was obsessed.
>> Yeah. Because it was like real. It was a
real a real encounter. Fire in the Sky
and a movie called Communion.
>> Yep.
>> With Christopher Walkin. Yeah. So weird.
But both those movies were based on true
stories. And so I was like obsessed with
those movies and I was like so obsessed
with aliens but terrified to be abducted
at the same time. And uh I was I you
know I grew up in a Christian home but
by age
12 like left altogether left the whole
faith because Christians didn't have
good answers for my tough questions. And
so I started dabbling in the occult
world. Internet was new. I was, you
know, the craft came out and so I was
dabbling in that, looking up the forums
and stuff way before Facebook or
anything. And looking up like do spells
work, all this stuff. Getting into the
occult, trying to look for ghosts out in
the graveyards, playing with Ouija
boards, all that stuff, and obsessed
with aliens, but thank God never had any
kind of encounters. But I watched all
the stuff, you know, I saw the alien
autopsy, bro, on Fox. It's got to be
real,
>> right?
>> That it's got to be real, man. And I I
would see all these things. It's like a
little leak here, you know, is on this
on this mainstream propaganda platform,
controlled platform. But I was like, I'm
on to it, man. They I'm I'm seeing the
declassified or the, you know, the
classified stuff that got leaked out.
And even today, they they still have
whistleblowers, right? Whistleblowers
that come out on Fox News,
and they're making a big deal about this
documentary, a age of disclosure, right?
And it's making mainstream media news.
So, there's been a soft disclosure for
like five years. So,
>> at least.
>> Yeah. When I was growing up, it was all
swamp gas and weather balloons, you
know, Roswell, all that stuff. But then
I made a documentary, a 35minute
documentary on Little Light Studios
called Disclosed,
kind of about my testimony of where all
this led me. But um yeah, the the
military finally started saying around
2019, right before COVID happened, you'd
start seeing these interviews on the
news with uh military and stuff and
they're like, "Yep, every day we see
stuff every day. We don't know what it
is. And then
December 2019, we got a space force all
of a sudden. And then and then right
after that, COVID happened and there was
this huge more than 5,000page document
that was uh all about COVID relief
legislation. And in there, for some
reason, was and we want you to disclose
everything you know about UFOs. like
what do UFOs have to do with COVID? But
when you watch the newscasters during
COVID when it first happened, they were
saying there's been double the sightings
since CO happened. So, so during CO, for
some reason, there was double the
sightings.
>> The stage is being set. Like everything
is ramping up. So, yeah, the military
says we see them, we don't know what
they are. They start saying, "Well, it's
not our technology. It's not their
technology. So, what is it?" And then
they start saying, "Oh, NHI. Yeah, we're
communicating with non-human
intelligences." Then they start having
those are like the the whistleblowers
that make it on mainstream television.
But then they start going to the US
congressional hearings and they're
saying, "Yep, you know, you got like
five or six guys up there, all you know,
military dudes, government officials,
and they're saying, "Yeah, we've been
communicating with nonhuman
intelligences since the 1930s." And they
say, "Well, are they alien?" and they
say, "Well, we don't really know what to
call them. We don't know what kind of
box to put them in. Uh, they could be
interdimensional." Um, so, and then you
have people like Steven Greer who's
saying, "Yeah, you can go out in a field
and and meditate." C C4 or C5 C5
where you there's like an app and
everything like you just go out to a
field and meditate and these things will
appear. And so what I'm getting at is I
believe that there's this whole push to
make the people feel like they're in
control. Like we No, we saw the leak. We
saw the whistleblower. We demand you
tell us you you don't think we can
handle it, but we deserve we we demand
to know the truth. And then you got all
of a sudden right now coincidentally you
got Age of Disclosure coming out,
Stephen Spielberg making his movie about
that very thing like 7 billion people
deserve to know the truth and all this
stuff. It's all propaganda. It's all
predictive programming to prepare us to
they're about to have disclosure I
believe probably next year.
>> Full disclosure.
>> Yeah. I think I I because I already I
thought it was going to happen this
year, but now all the attention is on
three Atlas and you know NASA's saying,
"Oh, it's just a comet." But then you
got Avi Lo being like, you know, this
Harvard science professor being like,
"No, it's it's too big. There's not
enough space dust to make a a meteor the
size of Manhattan, and it's got these
plumes coming off of it, and it's
changing color, and it's accelerating
unnaturally." And so it's it's this
whole psychological warfare where again
they're trying to make you feel like
you're you're finding out the truth.
Like there NASA's the one that's
covering it up. Oh, the government
shutdown, right? Conveniently when they
had the pictures and that's what Aby was
saying. Aby's on the news every day
saying, "Oh, there's this isn't normal."
And that NASA's like, "No, it's normal."
And so it's this big battle, right? And
you're like, "They're hiding something."
But it's all part of the plan. It's a
psycho. It's a scout.
Yeah, I got you. And and again, Avi is
was a was an easy guy because you could
tell he likes being on the news. So
therefore, once he figured out, it's
like, well, all I have to do is say
maybe there's, you know, it's it has all
these indicators. It's a spaceship. It's
all he has to do. And it's like, oh my
god, the phone's ringing off the hook.
He's never going to stop at this point
until that thing is long gone. And then
it'll be like, we missed it. That was
our chance. We should have called out to
him. But you know what's happening right
now? Europe, they said even though this
is, you know, they're still saying even
though this is nothing, it's just a, you
know, at the closest it's going to be
like 236 million miles from Earth. They
said it's made us realize that we need
to prepare because space is so
unpredictable.
So Europe is like the forefront working
with all the milit or all the space
agencies of the world to begin training
in intergalactic training. We're going
to protect Earth from an outside threat
>> and we know there's no such thing.
There's just a firmament with water
above us. So what are they really
preparing for?
>> Yep. There you go.
>> I don't know. So when you say that
there's going to be disclosure, what do
you think they're going to disclose?
Like what? like they're gonna put up the
that aliens are real or what?
>> Yeah. So, they're they're preparing. We
know predictive programming is real. I
mean, they did it with 9/11. They did it
with all these things, right?
>> And they're putting out the documentary.
Like the age of disclosure was like the
biggest thing ever. Like you have real
government officials saying, "I'm only
speaking out because I'm with others
that are speaking out. if I wouldn't
have ever done it alone because my life
would be threatened. So, I mean, they're
all saying this stuff and uh you know,
you got this three eye atlas and what is
it? So, I believe next year
um they're just going to say, "Look,
we've we we didn't want to instill fear
in people. We didn't want to panic
people, but we can't hide it any longer.
They are here. They're among us. But
don't worry, they've been with us for
thousands of years. They've been living
amongst you. You never knew it. They've
actually helped us. They've disarmed
nukes. They care about us. They're here
to help our society because u we don't
know how to take care of our
environment. We have climate change. We
we don't know how to use energy sources.
They're going to give us like free
energy like Tesla who got killed.
They're going to get rid of pandemics.
They're going to they're going to be the
cosmic saviors that come and fix all the
world's problems so that humanity will
win their trust because full disclosure
here, I believe that aliens are demons
in disguise. That these are
interdimensional deceivers who've
created this whole mythology and lore
about themselves deceiving humanity.
Because the question I asked was, what
are they what are they preparing for? If
there's nothing but a dome up there, why
are they preparing humanity to get ready
to battle some intergalactic threat
that's coming? Because the Bible
actually says it. Prophecy. According to
prophecy, I believe everything we've
been seeing is prophecy being fulfilled.
And what's the next step? I don't know
if I can get a a full screen on this
picture here, but this is Bible
prophecy. And it says, "And I saw three
unclean spirits like frogs, for they are
the spirits of devils working miracles."
Frogs, guys. If if we literally believe
the Bible and prophecy and it's all
coming true already, it says, "Three
unclean spirits like frogs are the
spirits of devils working miracles which
go forth to the kings of the whole earth
and and of the world and gather them to
the battle of the great day of God
Almighty." So this is literally what
we're living this right now. All the
kings of the earth, all the military of
the world are saying, "Yes, they're
real. Yes, we communicate with
interdimensional beings and when full
disclosure comes and they say they're
amongst us. They're here to help us.
They disarm nukes. They're going to give
us all, you know, they're going to cure
everything performing miracles like it
says, lying, signs and wonders. Once
they gain the trust of humanity,
then these beings are going to say,
"We've come here for a bigger purpose.
We know that there is an evil alien
invader trying to take over your planet
and without our help you're never going
to survive. Humanity is going to be
wiped out. But we have come to help you
in this battle. And that's exactly what
it says. It says all the humans of the
world, all the militaries of the world
are going to unite with demons, these
frog devil spirits, and fight against
the coming of Christ. But the whole
world is going to be deceived into
thinking, "Oh, we live in this vast ever
expanding vacuum of a universe and
there's aliens from another distant
galaxy coming to take over." And so
while humanity's thinks they're teaming
up with good aliens to fight against bad
aliens, they're really teaming up with
devils in disguise fighting against
Christ and all his angels.
>> It's about to happen. It is a wild
theory and we're definitely on this side
more skeptical of anything that says
it's coming from space if we don't
believe in it, right? If we're like,
look, there is no outer space, then we
know to keep an eye out. I think just
entertaining all possibilities is so
important. Um Steph or Karen, do you
have any thoughts on what he was saying
or have you?
>> No. Why? So that you know people think
>> I thought aliens were real until the
government said they were real.
>> Yeah.
You know, people think like, oh, if you
believe the Bible, it's really ignorant,
narrow-minded. But
>> you if you believe like the mainstream
narrative, like all the movies and
everything, then that's really kind of
more the simple-minded like, oh, yeah,
they're out there. The what's more like
expanding your mind and thinking like
outside the box is there's
interdimensional
beings who want to deceive the world and
they've created these oh oh we're going
to pretend that we're visitors from far
distant galaxies. The thing is these
things defy physics on every level. They
you can meditate and make them appear.
Their ships split into two, disappear
off radar, make 90 degree turns over
thousand miles an hour, can, you know,
crash into water without making a
splash. Uh they they abduct people right
out through their roofs. They speak
telepathically.
You know, everything about them is not
physical. They're not physical beings
from another world. So either we believe
the mainstream narrative that that's
what they are or they're something else
which I believe is more interdimensional
and deceptive.
>> Yeah. What do you guys any other
thoughts on what he said?
>> Earth made me believe in God and every
other crazy story makes me believe it
even more.
>> Right. That's what's up. Amen.
>> It's wild. I mean I was following the
like Mikey, thank you. You did a great
job of summarizing that theory cuz I've
been picking up on that stuff,
especially getting back to Bob Lazar,
Roswell, all these things that they've
been slowly kind of disseminating. Each
generation has their sci-fi alien movies
and it kind of started with alien
invasion stuff and then sometimes you
get movies like Contact or Arrival where
they're kind of trying to um give us
knowledge and the Bible does warn of
those things. So, it is just, you know,
for the biblical narrative and the
people following that. Yeah, keep an eye
out if there is no outer space. Like I
said, this is so important to just know
what is the, you know, the world system
trying to to portray as real when as
flatearthers, we are so much more
skeptical of anything that says it's
coming from outer space. And um
>> I don't think Yeah, I don't think that
message is for the people that
understand flat earth. It's for the
people who haven't woke up yet. That's
the people that is being told that
story. They still keep believing all
that because that's the reality they're
still in. Everyone else, they hear that
and they just start laughing.
>> Hear what?
>> About aliens or anything like space
anything. If you're in flat earth and
you hear space anything,
>> it's you don't take that serious.
>> Yeah. And that's what you meant by
saying that's right? You're
talking about the space narrative.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm talking
>> Oh, good. I thought you were talking
about what I was saying. I was like,
>> no, no, no. I'm just saying that won't
if we're going to go into the space
thing, you know, when it comes to, you
know, flat earth, we we already turned
that part off.
>> And Founded Earth Brothers have a great
documentary called The Final Card where
they're playing into um Warner von
Braun's, you know, testimony that
allegedly he said to his secretary like
they're going to either a um act like
there's an asteroid impact coming, but
the final card is the alien invasion
card. And you know there's so many
movies and stories about this and now
with government officials former
military uh current military you know
disclosing like we see things in the sky
they're not from they're they call them
offplanet
entities right for a lot of that's what
they're trying to tell the public
flatter side's like well maybe they've
always been here and there's people that
you know don't subscribe to the Bible
and that's fair fine no problem the
Bible just makes a lot of bold
predictions to keep an eye out for and
you know that's like why study idea and
try to understand it because I'm like,
what if the book's right? But then
there's the people that are, you know,
still undecided maybe, but they know
anything with space is skeptical. And
that's what's really cool about flat
Earth and why I am no longer bored in
life because now there's so many things
to entertain and knowing that this place
is a really special realm, completely
different than the heliocentric model.
It's like no, those ones that's like I
don't know what's going on there. could
could be fake or could be something we
don't understand. I'm not sure. Any
other kind of wild conspiracy thoughts
you guys before as we start to wind
down?
>> Well, about this, I know I know the
government has technology way far
advanced than what we have. That could
be a a laser from a drone, you know,
just like almost like a a dot matrix
printer, but a laser or something. I
don't know. Because you could analyze it
and be like, well, it's not burnt. It's
I don't know what it's doing, but
like my worldview now and just to let
you know, I I was a antirist. I was
never atheist because I I was into the
paranormal. You can't be atheist and
believe in the paranormal.
>> But I was like totally against the Bible
>> until
2005. And then I started growing in like
2012.
And you know, the Bible talks about
Satan could take Jesus up on a mountain
or he could take him up on top of a a
high pinnacle and Satan could bring down
fire from heaven to uh to afflict Job
and and these swords and everything like
fallen angels and angels, angels in
general, good or bad,
can appear as men. I mean, the Bible
often talks about two men in white
apparel were standing asking, "What are
you gazing at?" You know, it's just like
they're men. They eat back in with
Abraham. They appeared and ate with
Abraham. He's making them food and
stuff. And so, they're physical beings.
I think sometimes we think that, oh,
these are just like these ethereal
ghosts or something, but they're
physical beings that can affect terrain
or or the weather. I mean, in the book
of Job, Satan affected the weather. So,
making some circles in the grass, you
know, I I look at some of these
magicians and stuff. And I I've always
been into like magic, you know, street
performance and all that stuff. Some of
it is definitely provably just
illusions, but there's some I'm like, I
think that we're being entertained by
demons. You know, you see a little ball
flying around and the whole crowd's just
like, whoa. And it's just some demon
like moving it around like this. It's
like, let me watch these pathetic humans
be in awe of me moving a ball around and
so making some circles in the grass.
>> Not not a big feat.
>> Fair points. Those are good points.
>> Um, all the world's a stage and we're
just players in it. uh everything that
that that we've seen tonight and
everything all the topics we cover I
think it's part of the everchanging
>> entertainment that is this world this
the school this perspective this realm
>> uh you know it's a test
>> enjoy the show
>> yeah we're we're here for a reason
>> uh you're not flying through the endless
vacuum of space you're not nothing that
can be snuffed out by at any moment by
any number of asteroids or gamma rays or
whatever. Uh you're you're here and uh
this place was built for you. So enjoy
it.